ti chiedo di
riflettere e ragionare su queste domande
ma non darmi le risposte dai la risposta
a te stesso ti senti valorizzato durante
le ore lavorative riesci a trovare o a
generare del tempo di qualità durante la
tua giornata
ti senti felice ci ha risposto no ad
almeno una di queste domande
io sono nel posto giusto
ok io sono un calabrese di ritorno ho
vissuto 15 anni in giro per l'italia
prevalentemente tra bologna e roma
ciò che andrò a fare in questi
quattordici minuti a raccontarvi la mia
esperienza personale
sperando che possa ispirare qualcuno di
voi sa cambiare vita
se ha risposto no una di queste domande
ok allora soprattutto nell'ultimo
periodo della mia esperienza romana
vivevo questa situazione in un modo
molto stressante
tornavo spesso a casa e non sia mia
moglie mi diceva fra ma io ti vedo
sempre a testa bassa come è possibile
questa cosa questo stress era generato
soprattutto da una stanchezza atavica
che mi portavo dietro perché pensate
cosa può voler dire dover spendere tre
ore del proprio tempo semplicemente per
spostarsi dalla casa dove si vive alla
casa dove si lavora tutti i giorni tutto
il giorno
questo succedeva perché noi cresciamo in
un ambiente che ci porta a competere in
un modo non sano una competizione
pensata per poter raggiungere qualche
livello all'interno della società
dobbiamo scalare e ambire a diventare
qualcuno in questa cosa diventava un
sentirmi massificato non riuscivo a far
emergere la mia identità non riuscivo a
far emergere chi realmente fossi e
generando questo senso di smarrimento
quindi a un certo punto ho detto ok
fermiamoci reset è come la lumaca piano
piano si muove portando dietro questa
grande casa che diventa anche un
a protezione durante il suo viaggio ho
inteso fare ritorno in calabria proprio
con l'obiettivo di cambiare
completamente approccio e nel farlo ho
dovuto togliere tutte le sovrastrutture
alle quali ero abituato e con le quali
ero cresciuto quindi ho dovuto
rivalutare completamente tutto il
contesto intorno a me
ri concettualizzato quelli che fossero i
valori più importanti e quindi le mie
priorità
la prima cosa che mi colpì tornando a
vivere in calabria furono i colori
venivo da una città dove il colore
principale intorno a me era il grigio
tornando a vivere al sud
ho iniziato a rivedere il blu del mare
il verde della campagna e questo in
mezza generava uno stato di equilibrio
molto più solido di quanto non fosse in
precedenza ma il vero cambiamento
partita a prendere coscienza del fatto
che la grande e vera ricchezza che avevo
non era la ricchezza economica quanto
piuttosto il tempo quando presi
coscienza di questo
iniziai a ragionare sul fatto che non è
tanto una questione di lavorare di più o
produrre di più e quanto piuttosto una
questione di lavorare meglio di fare
meglio di usare meglio il mio tempo e
quindi anche il vostro tempo
nasce così l'idea di avviare una nuova
esperienza aziendale insieme ad altri
professionisti usando una parola fin
dall'inizio otto anni fa che adesso è
molto di tendenza per chi ha visto la
serie su netflix oranges the new black
ho pensato e riconvertirle in smart
working is the new black perché è sulla
bocca di tutti ma mi piace condividere
con voi che cosa vuol dire fare smart
working intanto capiamo che cosa in
generale per qualcuno lavorare da solo
essere free lance di firenze possono
scegliere di lavorare da remoto quindi
da dove vogliono con il proprio pc
se replichiamo questa logica in una
logica aziendale iniziativa possiamo
iniziare a parlare di smart working noi
siamo abituati alle aziende piramidali
c'è un capo che ci dice che cosa
dobbiamo fare quando lo dobbiamo fare
quando lo dobbiamo fare è questa cosa va
fatta nelle 40 ore settimanali
se ci va di lusso è il nostro obiettivo
diventa raggiungere lo stipendio a fine
mese
lo smart working intende invece le
aziende in modo orizzontale siamo tutti
sullo stesso livello tutti contribuiamo
attivamente al raggiungimento di
determinati scopi che sono condivisi con
una visione ben precisa
ognuno di noi lavora sulle proprie
passioni
questa cosa può funzionare e in me ha
portato il cambiamento perché mettendo
al centro le persone facendole diventare
il sole il faro dell'azienda ho iniziato
ad avere molta più fiducia negli altri
molta più fiducia negli altri perché
ognuno di noi può gestirsi il proprio
tempo lavorativo come meglio crede
deve farlo però con grande
responsabilità perché il l'utilizzo del
mio tempo ha un impatto sul tempo degli
altri la responsabilità è uno dei valori
base per poter lavorare in smart working
anche e soprattutto perché lavoriamo in
una logica molto orientata al
raggiungimento degli obiettivi quindi il
mio alla mia domenica potrebbe essere il
mercoledì io potrei lavorare dal mare
dalla montagna o dalla campagna senza
una definizione di luogo fisico al cui
interno devo stare ma lo smart working
bello perché porta anche la trasparenza
trasparenza perché tutti sono al
corrente di ciò che viene fatto
all'interno dell'azienda anche e
soprattutto come le aziende in cassa e
investe le proprie economie
ma la cosa più bella che ha portato in
me lo smart working di potermi
arricchire nel collaborare con
professionisti da varie parti d'italia o
d'europa e poter iniziare
ad aprire il punto di vista interagendo
con loro quindi è un modo democratico se
vogliamo di lavorare dove non c'è non ci
sono filtri religiosi politici di genere
non c'è il problema più uomini o più
donne non dobbiamo pensare alle quote
rosa perché è tutto un approccio basato
su quanto possiamo e vogliamo essere
proattivi e quindi quanto soprattutto
vogliamo condividere la nostra
conoscenza con gli altri professionisti
che fanno parte dell'azienda quindi
iniziamo a parlare di work life fusion
questa che vedi è una foto vera ed è un
classico modo con cui noi intendiamo
spesso lavorare equilibrando il nostro
tempo lavorativo con il nostro tempo
personale cercando di farlo in una
situazione che sia meno stressante
possibile meno stressante possibile
perché al centro di tutto ci sono le
nostre passioni le nostre passioni
diventano inevitabilmente il nostro
lavoro perché l'obiettivo di tutti è
quello di raggiungere uno stato di
libertà e quindi di felicità lo smart
working tendenzialmente di documenti un
po in giro è basato su tre b la prima
sono i brics e sono gli spazi al cui
interno noi lavoriamo possiamo lavorare
all'interno dei co working quindi le
unità immobiliari spesso concepite come
in uffici diventano delle unità aperte
dove vari professionisti condividono
degli spazi per lavorare insieme
possiamo lavorare all'interno dei co
living quindi nuove forme di strutture
ricettive dove gli ospiti condividono
sia gli spazi abitativi quanto gli spazi
lavorativi possiamo lavorare a casa
nostra
quindi la casa che intendiamo spesso
solo ed esclusivamente da un punto di
vista della vita personale diventa
condivisione di spazio lavorativo e
spazio
privato
la seconda pisoni york i comportamenti
quella che vedi e nicotera e del piccolo
borgo di mare sulla costa degli ideali
dove ho scelto di andare a vivere
quindi dico è possibile tornare al sud a
questa domanda rispondo sì io l'ho fatto
è possibile vivere abbracciare la
lentezza del sud vederla come
un'opportunità sì è possibile
l'importante è mettersi in un'ottica di
eliminare le proprie sovrastrutture
capire chi sei capire cosa vuoi da te
capire quali sono le tue passioni e in
funzione di questo impostare un progetto
di vita
lo smart working ha un impatto positivo
sull'ambiente perché lavorando da casa
non mi devo alzare la mattina prendere
un'auto e fare
non so un'ora di strada per raggiungere
il luogo di lavoro non prendo m non
prendo bus o un impatto in generale
positivo sull'ambiente e il contesto
circostante ma è stata anche una grande
palestra di vita avendo vissuto sempre
nelle città
pensavo che qualsiasi cosa mi venisse in
mente la potevo acquistare non sono
andato al supermercato prendevo le
pesche a dicembre o prendevo i kiwi ad
aprile
questa cosa tornando a vivere in
calabria scoperto che una è un grande
fake esiste la stagionalità
ho capito che esiste la stagionalità ed
è stata una grande insegnamento anche
perché oggi vivo di tutto ciò che è
autoprodotto dalla mia famiglia quindi
supermercato lo completamente eliminato
se non per alcuni prodotti trasformati
l'ultimo avviso nibali noi spessissimo
utilizziamo il cellulare spesso per
gioco spesso per noi ha spesso per
apatia
ma questi strumenti ci consentono di
lavorare e di entrare in contatto tra di
noi
quindi grazie al digitale noi possiamo
creare delle relazioni umane pur
scegliendo luoghi diversi nei quali
vivere né penso ad esempio alla sana
come strumento per capire il chi fa cosa
e arredare la trasparenza in azienda di
modo che tutti sappiano su quali
progetti si sta lavorando
penso a slack che uno strumento di
comunicazione che ci consente appunto di
chattare e stare comunque in contatto
seppur non stando all'interno dello
stesso luogo fisico per lavorare penso a
zoom perché un grande problema del
lavorare da remoto e dello smart working
è che siamo spesso soli quindi bisogna
avere una grande autodisciplina
bisogna essere molto bravi a lavorare ad
obiettivi bisogna riuscire a superare il
freddo che spesso porta con sé il essere
da soli all'interno di uno spazio del
genere noi abbiamo cercato di metterci
il cuore in questa cosa e 15 abbiamo
aggiunto un acca a quello che
solitamente trovate in giro per la rete
la nostra h e lo human perché le persone
sono il nostro sole sono al centro del
nostro ragionamento
quelli che vedete sono 26 professionisti
che oggi hanno deciso di associarsi ad
aver mind proprio perché hanno voluto
cambiare
ognuno di loro sceglie vive in un luogo
diverso ognuno di loro sceglie come da
dove lavorare senza alcun vincolo di
orario si gestendosi in completa
autonomia
io vi lascio con questa frase che ben
rappresenta il mio percorso di
cambiamento
mi sembrava superfluo inventarmene una
io quando ci sono dei mostri sacri che
lo possono fare sicuramente meglio di me
e quindi questa frase rappresenta molto
bene questo tipo di percorso che ti ho
appena raccontato e che è il compito più
difficile nella vita è quello di
cambiare se stessi e vi invito a farlo